all right let's get started
my name is Kalyn Smith I'll be talking
to you about the basics of how to write
a compiler using llvm obviously in a
talk for an hour long I can't really go
into a whole lot of detail this entire
college curriculums and you can spend a
lifetime writing a programming language
right so this is only the basics it's a
very high level overview of what the
general process is and how you get a
binary at the end
first though who am I I'm Caitlin Smith
I am a senior software engineer at
Microsoft by day I don't work on any of
this stuff though that I'm going to talk
about there
um I'm also the creator of the method
script programming language and uh
I'll go a little bit more into what
methodscript does but it's a I've been
I've spent the last decade working on
that it's an up-and-coming language
that's somewhere between a toy language
and an alpha release please do not use
it for your production stuff but if you
play Minecraft it's actually mostly
that's where it's niche is right now so
if you run a Minecraft server you may
have heard of command helper which is a
plugin for the Java version of the
Minecraft server which allows you to run
method script in it and that's where
it's primarily used today so I have a
cool video a Minecraft video to show you
in a little bit
um but yeah if you have a throwaway
project or if you're just a language
nerd feel free to check it out it's
methodscope.com most of the presentation
is actually about llvm sorry uh yeah
we'll we'll switch to C halfway even so
it's not just about method script but at
least now you've heard of it
so here's the agenda there's just the
brief introduction of method script and
and compilers in general what they do uh
we'll talk about how you parse
the program whatever that is into an
abstract syntax tree the AST you'll see
this term come up quite a lot then we'll
take that AST and we'll compile it into
llvm code uh or and then object code and
finally a binary and actually most
interestingly
the optimizations that llvm does I think
that's a very interesting topic to kind
of cover so the objectives there's a lot
here and not everybody is a language
nerd so uh is there anybody here who
maintains their own compiler
one all right so yes just us so
um it's not exactly a popular thing to
have to do right but there's nonetheless
quite a lot in there does anybody write
regex
does anybody write complicated regex
does anybody write complicated regex and
then say God there's got to be a better
way
yes so usually compilers are the answer
to that and compilers should not be the
scary thing they're not just for
programming languages you can write
small domain-specific programming or
compilers that that work for whatever it
is that you're trying to do parsing
strings in general and a very generic
and
high performance way is almost always
better to do with a custom compiler than
it is to use regex not that I'm
suggesting you should throw away regex
it's useful and it has its place but
compilers are a good generic topic to
know a bit about
um and if you're a programmer it's also
good to know about these lower level
optimizations that happen and the
compile so pretty much every compiler is
an optimizing compiler so it's doing a
lot of stuff to kind of reef
re-transform your code into something
that's more performant
and it's important to kind of know what
those optimizations are or at least
could be so you can actually see the
code that you write isn't what runs it's
the binary and so knowing how you get
from the code to the binary and what
kind of things happen in there is is it
can be important for writing performant
code you don't want to over optimize you
also don't want to sacrifice readability
for optimization purposes when the
compiler is just going to do that
optimization anyways so it's important
to know this stuff even if you're not
planning on writing a compiler and if
you aren't writing a compiler talk to me
after
so a few disclaimers here I'm not an
expert I'm just three beginners in a
trench coat when it comes to lvm stuff
um
I don't know might be my answer for some
questions that are specific about llvm a
lot of the stuff that I do I just copy
from clang without question and uh and
some of it doesn't make sense to me or I
have a very very basic understanding of
what it is so but what I have works at
least and what I've got in the slides I
know about but beyond that I might not
be able to say a whole lot also native
method script which is compiling method
scripts to binaries rather than running
it in Java which I'll show you a diagram
of later that's just starting out so we
will swap to C Midway
um also the presentation uses llvm12 so
the current version is 15. the stuff
should all be still relevant but just in
case there's some differences there's
were a few versions behind
so here's uh hello world and Method
script
so hopefully you can understand what's
going on here we're assigning a variable
we are printing that variable out we're
printing out a red Hello World so
there's
a couple of functions here string
concatenation assignment variable
interpolation
basic stuff this is about as basic as
you can get without just messaging out a
string
here it is running in real life so it is
a real programming language but we have
a house here in Minecraft and we hit the
doorbell and we get a text message
so it's mostly used in Minecraft but
it's it's unbounded it is a real
programming language
this is what the code for that looks
like it's very little code so we're
binding to the player interact event if
that event happened at a specific
location in the game World then we send
an SMS and that's it so it's for what
you get uh it's it's a very
straightforward language it's easy to
learn I have a lot of people
who have told me that they couldn't
figure out JavaScript or whatever other
language and they played around with
method script and especially in in
Minecraft it's really especially younger
people it's very motivating so it's an
educational language in that sense
so how is a method script organized we
have the functions which are the
intermediate representation the AST
there's a compiler that takes the source
code and spits out this AST
there's tooling so there's an IDE and
stuff that kind of sits on top of that
these get output to the jvm which is
currently the reference implementation
and the most complete implementation and
this is what's running in Minecraft
um but what I wanted to do is that
because this requires the jvm and Java
and everything has to be installed what
I want to do is to actually compile to
llvm when you compile to llvm you get by
native binaries for free basically
um so these are the platforms and the
runtimes and for the Minecraft stuff
there's Minecraft functions like setting
getting blocks and whatever that kind of
sits on top of the jvm but that's not
really part of method script
um so a quick intro about llvm so
there's several languages or compilers
on the left here these are the front
ends so clang for C and C plus plus I'll
go for laying and rust C for rust and
then on the other side we have the
targets which are the CPU architectures
x86 arm power PC m1s all that's all
that's there was some is not really a
CPU architecture but I put it here
because it is a target
um so that's the web assembly if you're
familiar with that it's different uh it
doesn't really belong in this list but
it's nonetheless got a back end in love
that's at least partially supported uh
there's a lot I mean there's you can do
very real stuff with it but it's kind of
a newer technology maybe not so mature
but before llvm this is what it would
look like so every compiler writer that
wanted to Target each of these CPU
architectures would create a compiler
for each of those and each of these
lines represents a lot of work so if you
wanted to support uh you know Intel and
mac and whatever else you basically end
up writing two or three compilers some
of the work can be reused but the actual
conversion to the the assembly or
whatever that's got to be redone each
time so this is just a lot of work llvm
came in and said no no this is too many
lines so we're going to get rid of all
these lines we're going to sit on the
middle
and you're going to Target llvm as a
compiler writer and we will Target all
of these targets as llvm and what's cool
about this graph is first of all it's
less lines in general each line still
represents a lot of work but there's
less lines overall and each like person
has to only deal with one line so if
you're a compiler writer you just worry
about writing your compiler if you're a
CPU architect you worry about converting
llvm to your CPU but there's this kind
of standard abstraction layer sitting in
the middle
so llvm used to stand for low-level
virtual machine they want to be very
clear that it no longer stands for that
it's just llvm and it makes sense
because it is low level but it's not a
virtual machine in any sense of that
word maybe it was back when the project
started or whatever but it's it's uh
it's just an abstraction layer between
the compiler and the the CPU
um
there's also lots of optimizations that
llvm provides and what's really cool
about these is that if you write a new
optimization for llvm code everybody on
the left and the right benefits from
this so it's actually really impactful
if you can come up with some cool new
optimization on llvm stuff everybody and
the whole ecosystem benefits from that
Microsoft and Google are really starting
to bet big on llvm as well so
Microsoft's using it for Quantum
Computing projects clang has fully
supported in visual studio now Chrome
has ditched msvc for for clang on
windows so these are real production
projects these aren't little toy
projects or whatever llvm is really
getting some real traction it's actually
been around for a while it's been around
since 2000 when it was very first
started but it's you know it's very hard
to kind of break into this compiler
space and get people to use use your
stuff right so it's been a bit but it's
coming along and it's it's very much
maturing these days
foreign
ERS you know uh zero indexed and
floating Point means you can have quite
a lot of numbers in between right so
there's 3.0 easy steps to writing a
compiler uh first Sub-Zero is uh to
design the language and this is just
left as an exercise for the reader it's
got an infinite number of points between
there though
um the next step is to compile the AST
compiled to llvmir which IR is the
intermediate representation this is kind
of the human readable assembly it's not
really assembly but it kind of looks
like it
um and or bit code bit code and IR are
one to one but obviously for
presentation purposes it's it's much
better to show you the IR not the bit
code so I'll be using that but those are
interchangeable
uh and then finally you use the llvm
tool chain to create the native binaries
so let's talk about compiling the AST so
what is an AST what is an abstract
syntax tree so let's take the simple
program two plus three plus four this is
a program we could also rewrite this as
a a prefix notation also known as like a
just regular function call so we're
calling the function add and we're
sending it the parameters two three and
four and this is what the tree would
look like for this program so at the
root we have the function itself and
then any arguments that are passed are
Leaf nodes the leaf nodes can also be
other function columns as well so it's
not just it doesn't have to be these
Atomic values or whatever it can be much
more complicated but for this program
this is what the AST looks like and this
is kind of the uh data data structure
representation of a program
so how do we get that the first step is
to Lex so Lexing is when you take the
program and you read it in one character
at a time
and the lecture knows about certain
specific types of characters like left
left parentheses and commas and things
so what it sees in this program is ADD
left parentheses two comma 3 comma four
right parentheses
it says that a D and D go together
that's one lexime or one token and so we
create an identifier is what this is
called and we actually need a bit more
context to be able to say what it is
identifying that comes later in the
parsing step but we get each of these
tokens here uh that are that are kind of
combined into their logical lexime
uh next the partial takes over and it's
it sees that there's an identifier here
that's followed by a left parenthesis so
that must mean that this is a function
call
um so we we create the kind of top level
node there
left parenthesis means we start a new
row on the tree so we go down one level
uh if we if we encounter a right
parentheses we go up a level comma means
start a new new node on the same row
conceptually it's pretty simple to
explain I think
um
it can definitely be difficult it's
basically just a big switch statement in
your lecture there's a lot of other you
can generate if you write a grammar for
instance you can get these things for
free but I think it's just as easy to
write the actual lecture yourself
so once you have this AST it's just a
tree in memory the next thing to do is
to compile it to lvmr or the bitcode
directly if you're if you're using the
the apis and stuff
so the first step is to flatten the tree
this is basically just a depth first
recursion through the tree so so you you
get this flat structure here and uh then
we take this structure and we go from
top to bottom and we create the IR so
each node is kind of handled
independently from the rest so in that
previous tree that we had what we're
doing here is we're saying a the local
variable a equals the i-32 2 B is 3 C is
four
the add function has to do an
intermediate step because the add
instruction
provided by lvm only does you can only
add two numbers at once so we do add a
and b we store that into an intermediate
and then we do I that intermediate plus
C and then we sort that into the result
so this is real llvmir it's simplified
in the sense that there's some
boilerplate and stuff that I haven't
shown you but this is It's relatively
straightforward to understand especially
for something this simple and if you
know any kind of assembly you might you
might be like ah yeah yeah I recognize
this now
so here's the full program and this is
there's a lot of stuff here that you
don't really need to know the target
data layout at the top is saying that
we're using little ndn we're using
Windows name mangling here's the
alignment information the target triple
is interesting though this is what
architecture we're targeting and Tool
chains and stuff that we're trying to
emulate
um we're creating a global variable here
uh on this line here where where we
store the constant string hello world
which is uh length 14 I8 it's an array
of length 14 containing i8s
and it's a global variable that's what
the at signs mean
we're defining a method here Main and we
take some arguments these are ARG V and
Arc C then we're calling puts puts is
the C standard Library way of writing to
the console and we're sending it this is
complicated but we're basically getting
a pointer to this string here
um and so we're basically doing a system
out here and then we return zero we also
have a forward Declaration of the puts
because puts is defined in the C
standard Library we are not defining it
so we're saying
this will be here the Linker will fix it
so the compiler can move on with its
life
so here's a more complicated example
this is the Rand function and Method
script
um so you'll note the the red lines uh
it's kind of funny when you make a
presentation you look really really
critically about what you're putting in
the slides and I discovered a bug in
method script so I fixed the bug so
these lines are not there anymore but
what's even funnier is when I get to the
optimizations we're going to come back
to this example it doesn't actually
matter at all but I fixed the bug but
anyways the the red lines just ignore
those
so what we're doing in method script
Rand with no parameters returns a value
between 0 and 1 a double so the C
standard Library provides the Rand
function which returns an integer and
specifically on Windows it returns a
16-bit integer and I wanted more
discrete steps there between between
each value so what I'm doing is I'm
calling Rand twice and then shifting
left
the first one doing a bitwise or with
the second one doing an unsigned int to
floating point conversion of that value
and then dividing by the maximum Rand
number so that gives us a number between
0 and 1. uh we're not doing anything
with this value so we're just returning
0 after
but let's do something with it now
and by the way there's also the four
declaration here of this this round
because that's also provided by the
standard Library so now let's actually
output it so this code here is the same
as as on that last slide so don't um
don't get too hung up on that I'll zoom
in here
um so what we're doing this is a little
bit complicated because we we're we're
converting method script Concepts into
Concepts that the C standard Library can
support so it's not always like ideal or
whatever you just this is how you have
to do it so what we're doing is we're
using S printf to convert the decimal
number into a string because we know
we're about to Output it and we have to
do that conversion first so this is the
S printf we're doing it a Loca and all
of the stuff Alex I'll explain a local
later
um but esperanf here is kind of storing
the the converted value into the buffer
and then we output the buffer
so now let's build on this a little bit
more
so now we're going to call Rand store it
and a variable and then output that
variable and actually uh
yeah
so there's the same here is at the
beginning and at the end it's the same
stuff but we have this block here in the
middle that's new
and I will zoom in on that so what we're
doing here this assignment a Loca is an
important call this comes up quite a lot
so what this does is this allocates
memory on the stack and we are storing
the value of the output from the
previous operation in that stack
the the memory that we've allocated On
The Stack and then we're again loading
it back into a register so I these are
local variables the 10 and 11. they're
local variables but llvm allows us to
kind of think of them as registers
and llvm gives us an infinite number of
them obviously that's an abstraction
CPUs don't have an infinite number of
registers but we can think of the the
local variables as registers and then
whenever you're modifying something on
the stack you think of that as memory
but we'll come back to this when we get
to the optimizations so this is
inefficient though this is weird and
it's inefficient but the cool thing
about it is that if we look at the
actual code here
um oops
so this is uh the Rand function or the
output of the Rand function this is the
output of the assignment function and
this is the output of sys out and
they're totally independent from each
other so as a compiler writer I don't
have to really worry about the
interaction I just have to do what the
code said and so I take the the abstract
syntax tree and I print it out I do my
own optimizations on top first but once
I have my optimized version I don't have
to go too crazy with it
so the next step once you have this IR
code is quite straightforward it's it's
really just up to the llvm tool chain
after this so there's kind of a lot here
so I'll I'll focus on specific things so
the first step is to call LLC this is
the llvm compiler this takes as input
the LL file the IR that we had written
either by hand or through our
compilation process and we're saying we
want an object file
and you do this on a per file basis
then we call link and you can use any
system Linker or whatever but lvm has
its own which is what I'm using here we
send it all of these object files that
we had created and we're linking it with
the standard Library so these are the
this is where the Rand and puts
functions and everything else live in at
least windows in these lib files lib
files if you're familiar with dlls libs
are the the static include version of
dlls basically
there's a lot of other stuff there that
is you know
passed to things and whatever finally we
we output
main.exe so this is the tool chain so
once you've got the IR written this is
what you run and you get the the
binaries and this works more or less the
same on Linux and mac and stuff
so that's it that's how you write a
compiler but let's talk about some of
these optimizations because they're
really really cool
first on let's just review the memory
model of a computer so we have the
physical layer here
um
physical
the places that you can store memory in
a computer first is the CPU there's also
the CPU cache L1 L2 and sometimes L3 and
then finally RAM and it goes from
fastest to slowest we don't really have
a lot of visibility on the CPU cache it
just does that as part of the hardware
so we don't have a lot of visibility
into that but in and and then on the
logical level we have registers the
stack and then the Heap
all else being equal if you can if if
the the thing that you're trying to do
makes sense to do this for you want to
move that as far to the left as possible
so you would prefer that your memory is
always coming from the CPU
if it must come from Ram you would
prefer it to come from the stack and
then and then finally the Heap certain
problems
can't be solved you can't store a
dynamic array in the CPU for instance so
some problems must be put in a certain
location but again all else being equal
we want to move this as far to the left
as possible these memory accesses
so let's go back to this slide
so this is the the rent and then says
out
so what we're going to do first is we're
going to run the opt tool so
optimizations normally happen when you
use the tool chain assuming you don't
say oh zero but what we can do with the
Ops tools we can run specific
optimization passes so there's a lot of
them out there but if we want to see
each step one at a time what the
optimizations are doing we can use this
tool what I'm doing here is I'm calling
mem to Reg and it does what it sounds
like it moves any accesses that it can
from memory if we're if we're using the
stack or then it's going to try and move
those into register reads and writes
instead
so this is the same program as before
but what you what you notice now is that
I've basically this is the round call
here and this is the uh sysound call
we've kind of removed that middle
inefficient section because we weren't
actually needing to put that in in the
stack it was uh it could have been in
any value that's representable as an
integer including doubles which are just
basically integers with a fancy format
um those those all lend themselves to
being stored into the registers and so
llvm saw that and it said okay let's get
rid of these and put them into
into the registers instead
um you'll also notice that I'm using
these monotonically increasing numbers
on the left
that's because
lovm has this concept called Static
single assignment
and so what we can't do is we cannot
assign a value into a register more than
once so you can kind of think of these
values the the local variables as
constants so you can only assign them
once you can change the value if they
point to some value in memory you can
change the value of that memory but you
cannot reassign that register
it really is a weird way of thinking
about things but this is kind of what
enables that abstraction of infinite
registers and to be able to do some of
these optimizations
um so there's a really interesting
Wikipedia article on static single
assignment uh I if you're interested in
this anyways it's a good read
uh yeah so remember this this a loco
store load pattern
what do you do if you have to write a
value to it multiple times so maybe you
have an if block and some conditional
you either write one value or the next
that means you're going to have multiple
stores there but how do you do that how
do you move that to us this kind of
constant
everything's a constant
thing well let's take a look so here's a
simple C program
we are assigning we're declaring I and
then based on some user input we're
either assigning 42 or 7 to it and then
we're returning it
so let's do we're going to use we're
switching to C now so let's use clang
and we'll tell it to do no optimizations
at all and what this is what we get
This is complicated clang does a lot of
extra stuff that I can't really explain
but I've annotated the important bits
here so there at six is the Declaration
of of I
um we're doing the if the the
conditional and the if statement there
in the next section here so this is
where we do you know is ARG Arc C
greater than one if so we store that to
eight then if eight we go to 9 else 10.
in 9 we assign I to 42 and go to 11 down
here and then the else block here is set
I to seven and then again go to 11. then
we load the value that wasn't I into 12
and then return 12.
so how does it optimize this so let's
run reg mem to Reg on this
so we have the same comparison here this
is the ARG C is is less than one uh and
then and then break and either go to
four or five these are empty though
and we have this Phi node
so a fine note is an interesting concept
that kind of inverts
that you're thinking on its head so what
a fine note says is what what branch or
what block did I just come from
and if I just came from block four
then set return the value 42 and if I
just came from block five return the
value 7. and that's that's what this
output is is Health this is provided by
clang this is what clang outputs but
that's why because this says that from
block 6 we either came from block five
or four
and from from this block we we came we
always came from block two which is an
implied block two up here
um so there's still some additional
optimization to be done here but this is
this is how you do it this is how llvm
does it so we're back to not using
the the ram anymore it's all registers
now so this is really cool
the further optimizations of course we
remove the empty Branch statements there
and it doesn't even need a fine node in
this case a select is good enough and it
selected basically says if this value is
true return return based on that
so let's talk about Loop unrolling and
instruction combination this is a bit
more complicated of an example so here
we have some code where we loop from 1
to 10 exclusive and we increment ARG C
then we return rxc so what does this
code look like without optimization
this is a lot of code sorry I couldn't
get it uh any any shorter than this but
basically what we do is this is the anti
assignment in in the for Loop then we
have the if I is less than 10 part then
we do the guts of the for Loop which is
adding one two two I or sorry rxc is
what we had then we do the the last step
of the four which is adding one to I and
then depending on the values we we loop
back up to to the conditional or we exit
so there's there's a lot of stuff here
that is kind of irrelevant but we're
basically doing some ads more or less
right
um so
what if we do full optimizations what do
we get out of this
it's quite simple so actually this was a
very contrived example this is just a
really fancy way to add nine that's what
we were doing really and lvm saw right
through that and that's what it
converted it to after the optimization
so how did it do this this is actually a
really cool trick uh how does it know
how does obviously as humans we can look
at this code and say oh you're just
adding nine but how does the compiler
get to this generically well let's step
through it one optimization at a time so
the first step to run is the mem to
wrench which is pretty much a
prerequisite for most other
optimizations
this this code we ended up with a couple
of fine notes Here we still have our ad
here this is the adding one to rxc we
also have the ad for the counter
variable here
um this this block three here is is
rather complicated and not maybe not so
necessary to fully understand let's do
one more optimization which is loop
unroll
so Loop unrolling is basically where you
take you trade off program signs for for
runtime complexity
um so
um what we've basically done is we copy
paste
each internal of the loop nine times
and so that's what's that's what's
happened here but
we're still a long way from just add
nine so what's the next step the next
step is to do a simplified control flow
graph so what we what we actually what
you notice here is there's there's a lot
of stuff here that's like we're just in
Block 10 and we go to 11. i i there's no
absolutely no need for this so simplify
uh CFG
simplifies the control flow graph and
gets rid of these unnecessary breaks
jumps and stuff so this is kind of the
core of the loop here this is what we
end up with we add one and one and one
the next step is to instruction combine
so we combine instructions that are
basically the same so in this case it it
knows that the add instruction if we do
add one add one that's the same thing as
doing add two if we do it nine times we
could add nine and that's that voila
so
Loop unrolling can't always be done
uh we cannot solve the halting problem
so the first example that I showed you
was one extreme which was a constant
number of loop iterations The Other
Extreme is just a who knows how many
iterations
um by the way this is the output of that
fully up not optimized and then uh
the same process for this while while
user input so the loop unroll does
nothing basically
um and that's kind of what we expect
there's kind of a middle ground here
where we want to do some Loop unrolling
but not fully unroll it
and the reason that you would do this
actually these contrived examples for
the constant ones obviously you can do
that but
um you don't always want to do Loop
unrolling sometimes it's less efficient
and that can happen if you're if you're
just if your Loop repeat decision logic
is very very cheap and your innards are
expensive then
um there's probably not a whole lot of
reason to do the loop unrolling but if
your decision logic is extremely
expensive
then then it actually makes quite a lot
of sense to do Loop unrolling so I
actually couldn't figure out how to get
llvm to show me an example of this so I
just took an example from Wikipedia of
what Loop enrolling is and this is kind
of written in a higher level language
but it's the same concept so what we
have here at the top is we've defined
our Bunch size as eight
and we do a a modulo a division a floor
Division and then a modulo to get the
number of times we need to do the batch
repeat and that's what this is here so
in this case uh 50 divided by 8 is 6
remainder two so we'll run this big loop
here six times and then we'll have some
left over in this case two and we use
switch case fall through
to you know jump down to two and then we
do the remaining two there so this is
kind of loop unrolling in a more
reasonable example
so llvm contains a lot of optimization
so this is what you get when you do
actually I can't remember if this is O2
or O3 but it's a lot it's a lot of
optimizations and actually uh the the
ones that I've highlighted here are the
ones that I just talked about you'll
notice that a lot of them are repeated
and that's because some of the
optimizations will rewrite the code in
such a way that now this previously run
optimization can run again and it will
simplify it further the general rule is
not always of course with CPU pipelining
and whatever there's there's some
complexity in the statement but as a
general rule the less instructions that
you have the more efficient your program
is so generally speaking you want to
simplify it as much as possible and just
come up with the smallest file
anyways there's a lot in here I don't
know what half of these do but this is
what you get when you run O2 or O3
there's another tool in the opt tool or
another
a moat or whatever in the Ops tool that
shows the control flow graph which I
think is an interesting thing to see so
this can show you your you know
optimized or not and if you use like
graphvis or whatever you can see your
control control flow graph which can
maybe help you reason over what's going
on in your program especially if you're
handwriting the IR and you want to see
you want to see what's going on there
so the llvm language reference is is a
great place to read about individual IR
instructions and if you're writing a
language then this is this is the bread
and butter this is the API so you need
to be very familiar with us because
you're rewriting your language in terms
of what IR what llvm provides you in the
IR
it's changing constantly so it is it's a
bit of a moving Target and it's still
very much development
um but it's actually a pretty good
document there
there's some more uh references here for
optimizations there's a I mean obviously
you saw that big less a huge number of
them that I just didn't cover at all
like I said the SSA article on Wikipedia
is really uh really informative
my llvm is open source it's on GitHub
this this site here is really cool so
lvm is is quite low level in that it's
very nearly assembly
and so there's a lot of Concepts like
throwing exceptions and whatever one of
the state of design goals of llvm is to
be able to Target any any architecture
within reason I guess but not all
architectures support things like
exceptions and whatever so llvm does not
provide that so when you're mapping
these kind of higher level Concepts into
this lower level also doing things like
changing if statements into jumps and
things this this site here goes through
through that about how conceptually you
think about these things and how you
convert this higher level stuff into
into a lower level language in this case
lvm
ah if you liked the Minecraft demo so be
sure to check out method scripts if you
run a Minecraft server it's definitely
of interest to you but if you if you
like playing around with it if you want
to contribute as well here's a link to
to uh giving any PRS or whatever if you
feel so inclined
um but yes so that's it for me are there
any questions
yes what's the difference between
targeting the jvm and llvm in
yeah so the question was what's the
difference between targeting the jvm and
lovem so uh when you target the jvm it's
in the AST is interpreted inside of java
so the function Rand is just a wrapper
around Java's Rand function and it runs
directly so you it's basically it's it
is the run time and it interprets the
ASD whereas the llvm the output is an
executable and it's totally
self-contained so you don't need any job
or anything else
jvm bite God has a LLB Antarctic uh so
are there any plans for uh Java byte
code as an llvm Target I don't think so
I would like to do that myself so I
could in in theory I could put
um
I could put any
uh
let me see let me see if I can go back
I actually simplified this this graph
I've this I've I've used this in method
script pitch text before there's another
you could put another leg here at the
bottom for a DSL or whatever you know
you want to whatever thing you want to
Target and so it targets jvm right now
it interprets in the jvm but there's no
reason I couldn't just output jvm byte
code myself
um and a lot of the learnings from llvm
will certainly be useful there
but as a first implementation running it
as kind of in a semi it is compiled it
compiles to the AST but but then it's
it's interpreted
from there and that's an easier thing to
start with than a fully compiled
language
but yes it's it's less efficient to do
that and so it would be actually really
great to be able to Output the the Java
byte code as well
the optimization Stone
yeah uh so the question was uh multi how
does lvm support multi-threading I think
probably the answer is it it doesn't uh
it's it's something that you have to
manage yourself as the language designer
um so far I've I've not gotten into this
because I I'm just I'm I'm focused on
Hello World level right now but I don't
think there's I've not seen anything
that specifically because threads are a
higher level concept uh that the OS kind
of provides so my suspicion would be
that there's nothing specific in llvm
Mark something as volatile yeah
well it's it's using if it's using OS
threads it's going to have the the
contention resolution and things that
are provided in the CE Library basically
and this is standard Library so that's
probably what the answer is is that you
use these things that are provided in
the C standard Library
but I don't know
yes
yes there are so what what tools are
available for for verifying the
optimizations there's uh some bisection
tools for instance so so you run you
know you say I found the bug I think I'm
going to run half of the optimizations
and if the code output still works it
was in the other half and then try again
um I actually I I lurk in the IRC
channel for llvm and that comes up from
time to time that people are like
I think there's a bug in this
optimization and then that's basically
the advice to do this bisect and then
try and try and figure out which path it
is
using this opt tool basically and then
go go from there uh pretty much so
yes
yes debugging so that is an interesting
question I've only I've only scratched
the surface but what you can do is
um
you can output
I don't think I have this in examples
actually but you basically output dwarf
information as part of the binary
um and uh yeah I cut it out from this
example
um but you you basically output extra
information inside of the IR and inside
of this this file or through the bit
code that says that like this line of of
code came from this source source uh
identifier or whatever
and then tools like the gnu debugger and
stuff can just work with with that
um but I've only scratched the surface
obviously debugging is a super important
thing to be able to do
um so I very much want to provide that
functionality at some point
but very very surface level there
oh perfect
yes
sort of it's It's to not have to worry
about the assembly for that architecture
so if you were writing bare metal for
instance it should look the same in
everything but what we're doing here is
we're using
um uh
puts for instance is that's implemented
by Windows libraries or Linux or
whatever and so some of these vary like
the ram function for instance uh returns
a 16-bit value in Windows and 32-bit on
Linux so the IR does look different for
each platform and I do have to take
those things into account but at least
the CPU specific stuff is should be the
same the only thing in theory if you're
writing metal is the only difference
should be this target triple
um but yeah there are there are platform
differences still so it's not a perfect
abstraction
yes yes so what I'm doing right now is
that I'm basically just copying what
clang is doing for alignment in each
platform
um but yeah uh the the alignment would
probably be CPU specific as well
so
any other questions
support for Unicode
um
I don't know
I don't know so this is
yeah that's a good question I'm not sure
I'm not sure
I think that's probably going to come
down to
because you can put whatever you want
here and I think it's going to come down
to whatever you support as the compiler
you're going to read in some text file
basically and then you're going to
output something else so as long as you
output something that this string can
can process maybe you have to do escapes
or whatever then I guess it should be
possible
I don't know
yeah
yeah I I I'm sure I'll I'm sure that lvm
doesn't care uh because you're just
passing in these opaque strings from
your language to to the whatever the
like in this case puts so I'm sure it's
it's basically up to you to support
any other questions
well I'd like to thank you for your
attention I hope you got something out
of this uh you know it's it's a kind of
a niche topic of course and but it's
really great to see so many other
language nerds here so thank you all for
your time
[Applause]